[Musique]
daniel gros désir bonjour bonjour
monsieur ligori bonjour aux à vos
auditeurs et particulièrement à ceux du
marigot
alors daniel gros désir vous avez 61 ans
vous êtes agent de la poste vous étiez
membre de l'actuelle majorité municipale
5e adjoint au maire du marigot vous avez
démissionné en avril 2019 et vous allez
conduire la liste ensemble bâtissons
notre avenir
daniel gros désir pourquoi vous avez
décidé d'aller à la bataille décidé
d'aller à la bataille puisque en 2014 je
suis membre d'un mouvement politique qui
s'appelle marigot uni pour le changement
et nous avons fait alliance avec eux ne
se désespère as pour mettre fin à la
décadence de la ville qui durait depuis
un certain nombre d'années est en cours
de route nous nous sommes aperçus que
c'était pas du 12 du tout ça nous avons
insisté pour essayer d'amener fléchi et
améliorer des choses ça n'a pas
fonctionné
donc mon groupe et moi nous avons pris
la décision de laisser deux le conseil
municipal
et puis de proposer au marigot tint une
nouvelle voie pour pouvoir aider la
commune qu'est ce que vous reprochez aux
meilleurs exactement une il est toujours
en train de décider seul et ce sont
souvent des mauvais des décisions
inappropriées à la situation de la ville
l'autoritaire cpdc même pas l'autorité
c'est je peux vous dit pas qui des kids
autoritaire ira jamais crié dessous quoi
que ce soit non et c'est le
fonctionnement la gestion qui est qui et
qui est solitaire assez solitaire et que
donc qui ne va pas dans le sens pour
améliorer dalle de cadeau de la vie
vous m'avez dit que vous avez
démissionné il ya eu non mais pourquoi
20 attendu aussi longtemps
positionné oui c'est à dire que avec mon
groupe nous on pensait que ça allait
changer je l'avais vous êtes dans un
groupe vous dit peut-être que ça va
s'améliorer peut-être des fois on a dit
dédé cindy bon peut-être qu'on va
changer on va aller mieux on va pas une
telle décision et ira donc on reporte on
repose mais à un certain moment de débat
ces farines vont obliger point décision
quelles sont les grandes lignes de votre
programme de notre organisme pour le
programme s'est déjà remettre que
l'attractivité au niveau du marigot
c'est peut-être cette attractivité on a
un gros problème au niveau économique
et vous savez qu'il ya des plans qui ont
qui sont passés malheureusement sunu
mais un art nouveau qui est arrivé
depuis janvier 2019 parce qu'on a faim
il y avait le plan de de de l'été
réhabilitation des zones rurales et que
maintenant on se rend compte qu'on peut
changer changer des choses avec la zones
franches d'activités nouvelle génération
qui est en opération depuis 2000 dès
2019 et que certaines communes au
bénéficie à la matinée qui n'a que 12 et
qui peuvent bénéficier il n'y a que 12
et le marigot ont fait partie alors
qu'est-ce que ça permettrait de fait
alors ça permet à des gens qui ont
couvert monty qui ont déjà une
entreprise sous la ressource ou la ville
où des gens qui veulent venir investir
la ville de bénéficier des exonérations
d'impôts de charges qui sont
intéressantes et c'est même plus été
sans qu'avant parce que maintenant c est
définitif va peut-être à disque avant
c'était sous 5 ans et de sa permettra à
des gens de venir investir sur le
marigot pour pouvoir en bénéficier
ça c'est la trique d'activité économique
alors être ensuite ensuite
l'attractivité au niveau activité des
spiritueux du marigot
je dirais même pas que c'est obsolète si
quasiment inexistant on n'a pas de stade
on n'a même pas un terrain de handball
on n'a pas de salle d'animation est ce
que chaque commune doit avoir
obligatoirement un stade à l'heure
actuelle c'est pas et la lente la façon
dont fonctionnent les secondes ça peut
être mutualisés support à la façon dont
ça fonctionne à
martinique on est obligé d'avoir un
minimum d'effort de suture quand on dit
qu'on a un stade on n'a pas besoin d'un
stade avec grande tribune etc
mais vos jeunes qu'est ce qu'ils font
que ce qui est en train de se passer
concrètement vous vous avez un enfant
vous avez une quarantaine d'années vous
avez un enfant qui fait du sport il va
on peut aller lui dire bon allez olla
aller à cette mary 2 qu'est-ce qui se
passe il va aller au loin pour faire son
sport et puis la famille va déménager
carrément aller ou non et c'est ce qui
nous arrivait nous avons perdu plus de
450 habitants en cinq ans des cinq
dernières années
c'est très grave pour la commune parce
que à la vitesse où nous sommes partis
dans cinq ans nous sommes à 2500 alors
il ne reste pas grand chose que l'on
veut comme étant une reste à peine 20
secondes on expliquez nous ce concept de
conseil des sages en 20 secondes
côté écossais de change et conseils de
quartier et conseil municipal des jeunes
c'est à dire nous ne voulons plus de la
de fonctionner verticalement faut qu'on
fonctionne horizontalement auprès des
gens aller vers les gens pour que tout
le monde puisse participer donner ses
idées et faire remonter pour que la
municipalité puisse prendre des
décisions convenable pour tout le monde
daniel gros désir je vous remercie
je vois mais je vous remercie